[Music]
on this sunday night
pope francis arrives in canada i asked
the pope to walk with us in this new
journey the prayers for reconciliation
as the penitential pilgrimage begins how
residential school survivors are
fighting through trauma on this historic
visit a canadian dead in the dawn bass
ukraine's eastern conflict zone remains
under russia's relentless attacks
fearing heat smothering the u.s
sheriffs came up they go you got to go
now it's just like a hurricane
soaring temperatures and bone-dry
conditions fueling wildfires and flash
droughts
plus canada's golden boys it's a great
feeling you know after having the season
i've been having andre degrasse's race
to beat covid and take a top prize at
the world championships
[Music]
global national with bara nasser
reporting tonight tracy tong
good evening and thanks for joining us
after months of planning and preparation
pope francis has officially landed on
canadian soil he touched down in
edmonton to begin a journey of
reconciliation
[Music]
[Applause]
after years of pleas for the pontiff to
come to canada to personally acknowledge
the devastating toll of church-run
residential schools on indigenous lives
today pope francis was greeted on
arrival by the people and culture those
institutions once sought to erase
compelling scenes that will no doubt
also shape his trips to quebec city and
ecallute over the next six days
the visit is already evoking a spectrum
of emotions from canadians as sarah ryan
reports in our top story
everyone is watching and waiting to hear
what the pope has to say on the catholic
church's role and responsibility in
generations of anguish
after a lengthy 10 and a half hour
flight from rome the leader of the
catholic church pope francis has arrived
using the support of a wheelchair to
relieve strain on his ailing knee the
same one that's limited his mobility
recently and led to the recent
cancellation of a trip to africa
francis otherwise appeared well smiling
at those who came to greet him
fittingly the first to welcome the pope
to edmonton was canada's first
indigenous governor general mary simon
followed by the grand chief of alberta's
treaty six first nations george arkhan
jr and then the prime minister
[Applause]
the latest step on the path to
reconciliation the reason for the pope's
visit front and center
[Applause]
grand chief arkhand called the meeting
humbling adding he asked pope francis
directly to walk with indigenous
canadians on a new journey come in
talk and apologize to our survivors so
that we could begin our journey of
healing and that we can begin
the opportunity to change
the way things have been for our people
for many many years
around 25 dignitaries were introduced to
the pope sunday including elders and
residential school survivors all are
keenly aware of the church's role in the
residential school system all awaiting
an apology on canadian soil
it's a long time coming
for the people that suffered in the
schools
but i'm glad
to live the day
that i seen it edmonton's mayor called
the pope's arrival a chance for the
start of a new chapter
we should never be afraid
to talk about what went wrong
but with also with
the view that we need to move forward
together to build a better future for
all of us pope francis now 85 years old
was escorted through the hangar
surrounded by security and into a small
waiting fiat to be escorted into
edmonton the first stop on his three
city papal visit
although it is sunday the pope will not
be celebrating mass instead he will be
resting here at st joseph seminary in
central edmonton catholics we spoke to
outside the basilica are also eager to
hear from him i think all catholics are
really excited for him to be here but at
the same time we recognize as a somber
occasion we have been praying for weeks
now that it's going to be a really
good visit for the pope that he'll be
welcomed
and that there will be a spirit of
reconciliation like we haven't seen
before some were able to snag tickets
for the pope's open air mass this week
some 60 thousand people are expected at
commonwealth stadium on tuesday
it will be
a dream come true
but on his first day in canada the pope
chose not to speak publicly reserving
his opening statement for monday in
muskratis where he'll apologize for the
church's role in residential schools
when you own up to a wrong
that's when reconciliation can start
the pope has arrived canadians across
the country now wait to see if his
presence here can help the healing begin
sarah ryan global news edmonton
well for many indigenous canadians the
pope's visit will be a source of healing
but not all residential school survivors
feel this way for those living with the
trauma of a lost childhood lost language
and culture the pope and the church
bring up a lot of complicated feelings
this week will be a deeply triggering
event heather yurix west has more
to watch perry omiesu on camera and in
the kitchen in one of his many youtube
cooking videos you can't help but smile
he has a unique ability to spark joy in
others even as he carries a heavy
sadness within
to the day i die that darkness is going
to be in my heart and it's never going
to go away it's never going to go away
and
yeah so it's been difficult
more than 1200 kilometers from his home
in squamish bc the source of that
darkness is now marked with a memorial
stone
it was here that the urbanskin
residential school stood for more than
80 years omiyasu was forced to attend
when he was just five years old i had a
good spiritual kind of upbringing and
then they took me away from that and put
me into indian residential school
and what a change heather what what a
difficult and
and ugly change in my life i didn't know
how to speak any english until i got
there and my cousin said don't get
caught speaking cree or you're going to
get hit
for like a year you know i hardly spoke
to anybody i felt so alone
omisu is now a mental health counselor
and a father to three adult sons
healing he says is something he's had to
work at every day it just kept getting
triggered and every time they go to a
new residential school and found more
bodies at these other residential
schools it would get triggered again but
for him the pope's visit will have no
part in that healing
like that's not for me if i can say that
it's like that that the whole thing is
not for me
paving the road through musco cheese was
prioritized in anticipation of the
pope's visit omiyasu wonders why that
wasn't done for the community before
he says a papal apology alone won't fix
the inequities indigenous people
continue to face i hope the pope can
have a cup of tap water while he's there
and drink that
still the visit will put the truth of
canada's residential school system in an
international spotlight highlighting not
only the pain of the past but
present-day injustices indigenous people
deal with daily within canada's
institutions from health care and child
welfare to justice and housing
acknowledging and illuminating these
issues is what gives omiyazu hope i
think when my sons are older when
they're men and they have children i
think their their sons are going to be
just such in a better place you know
they'll be able to walk with their heads
up and say oh they're indigenous i want
the world to know that it's like you
know that we want to get past this too
but for omnia true reconciliation is a
work in progress that must continue long
after the holy father returns home
heather urex west global news muscular
cheese alberta
and a reminder that if you or someone
you know is a residential school
survivor and is looking for help you can
call the residential school survivors
and family crisis line the number is
1-800-721-0066
and we will have full coverage of the
pope's six-day visit to canada right
here on global national global news dot
ca and our other online platforms
global affairs canada confirmed today
that a canadian citizen died recently in
ukraine in a statement a canadian
foreign ministry spokesperson says
global affairs canada is aware of the
death of a canadian in ukraine and
consular officials are in contact with
the family and are providing consular
assistance no further details are being
made public due to privacy
considerations
media reports suggests the canadian was
with two u.s citizens who died in the
donbass region in ukraine's eastern
conflict zone
and staying in ukraine the country's
forces seem set for a counter offensive
to take back more russian controlled
in a territory address ukraine's
president vladimir zelensky says troops
are now moving step by step into the
southern kerasan region which fell to
russia with little resistance early in
the war
ukrainian artillery strikes have
recently targeted and damaged key river
crossings in the region if destroyed
they could cut off crucial supply lines
to russian forces there
earlier this month ukraine had urged
area residents to flee to avoid getting
trapped in a counter attack
and russian foreign minister sergey
lavrov began a tour of african nations
to rally more allies over moscow's
conflict in ukraine in his first stop in
cairo lavrov reaffirmed russia's grain
export commitments to egypt after the
crisis disrupted supply shipments
a destructive wildfire in california is
burning out of control forcing nearly 3
000 people to evacuate
the oak fire near mid pines in mariposa
county has grown to about 60 square
kilometers it has destroyed 10 buildings
and cut power to more than two thousand
homes and businesses
hot weather steep terrain and bone dry
conditions are fueling the flames
california's governor has declared a
state of emergency near yosemite
national park due to that raging
wildfire and a blistering heat wave
baking much of the u.s this weekend is
expected to make the fire fight much
worse
over 90 million americans are under
extreme heat warnings or advisories
tonight jennifer johnson reports
sweltering temperatures are burning up
the northeast u.s this weekend with high
humidity making it even more unbearable
and dangerous
it's too hot it's too hot right now the
heat is so oppressive boston's triathlon
had to be postponed and a similar event
in new york was shortened with
participants told to take precautions
extra water yeah and we have medical
staff on site just in case anything does
happen we've got trained professionals
here but now there are grave concerns
about tens of thousands of new yorkers
who can no longer apply for cooling
assistance benefits used to pay
increased utility bills or buy air
conditioners because funds have run out
there has been such a big demand
for this program given the heat wave
the applications went up from about ten
thousand to thirty thousand that um the
state
has had to freeze its program senator
schumer is asking the biden
administration for additional money
before more people die in this dangerous
heat
millions are flocking to community pools
but at least a fifth of them in
philadelphia are still closed due to a
lifeguard shortage with the high
temperatures come big crowds and it
becomes a lot of pressure on lifeguards
sitting up there especially in heat it
can be very dangerous
don't let dehydration ruin your vacation
with deaths already being reported and
dozens of hospitalizations for heat
exhaustion and heat stroke doctors are
warning people to keep hydrating if
you're outdoors symptoms can begin as
quickly as 20 to 30 minutes it's about
the amount of time that you're exposed
to the heat and then also what you're
doing while you're in that heat it is a
sweltering hot day here in boston today
manager john schneider's feeling at 34
celsius the show went on in boston as
the red sox took on the blue jays in the
heat and high humidity a hot day of play
for the red hot blue jays
as medics keep an eye out for fans
braving the high temperatures to see the
game
jennifer johnson global news washington
coming up an accused killer's escape in
b.c and how he may have thrown police
off his trail
we are tracking developments in british
columbia tonight after a man on trial
for murder escaped from a metro
vancouver correctional facility law
enforcement agencies in canada and
around the world were alerted to the
escape and the rcmp released photos of
two suspected accomplices now it turns
out the photos of the two men shared by
police were stock photos available for
purchase to anyone on the internet
catherine urquhart reports
at north fraser pre-trial center in port
coquitlam members of the rcmp
investigate how an accused killer
escaped rabbi alkalil broke out of the
maximum security facility thursday night
al khalil's
connections range from across canada to
the united states
europe and asia a canada-wide arrest
warrant and an interpol red notice are
being prepared alkalil is charged with
first-degree murder for the high-profile
and very public 2012 shooting death of
gangster sandy dewer in the sheraton
wall center after the murder
robbie alcaleel fled the country when a
number of search warrants
were executed by the vancouver police
homicide unit
in quebec
we believe he was working in concert
with other suspects investigators are
not confirming how he managed to escape
the facility but there are reports a
plasma cutting torch was used to cut a
hole in the fence he fled in this white
econoline van which has since been found
north fraser pretrial has had escapes
before in 2007 surveillance video showed
37 year old omid tavili dressed as a
janitor being escorted out by a guard
who was promised fifty thousand dollars
to aid in his escape tavilli an
organized crime kingpin has never been
caught the guard never received his
money and was sentenced to three years
in prison
now the latest escape there will most
definitely be a a full-scale review and
investigation into what happened and how
it happened katherine ercart global news
vancouver
ahead personal freedoms under attack in
the land of the free
in the u.s the reality of roe versus
wade falling shocked a country that has
grown accustomed to having rights over
personal health decisions
since then the democrats have been
seeking to shore up support to protect
americans from having more rights taken
away in the future by the conservative
leaning court reggie shakini reports
across the land of the free personal
freedoms have come under attack our
opponents are working to take women's
rights away in june the supreme court
for the first time in its history
rescinded legal rights by overturning
roe versus wade justice clarence thomas
writing in the landmark decision that
other high court rulings could be next
to fall when justice clarence thomas and
the other justices said if it's not
written in the constitution that you
don't have that right
that should send um you know shivers
down the spine of anyone conservative as
well as progressive house democrats
frequently criticized for passive
politics under the biden administration
raced to put rights at risk up for a
vote to codify into law
including abortion rights the bill is
passed
same-sex marriage the bill has passed
and this week the bill is passed access
to contraception i'm appalled
that we have to vote on this damn bill
at all
the u.s
is now
standing alongside nicaragua honduras
poland you know other countries that
have more autocratic regimes with
democrats majority passing these bills
in the house was expected but republican
support even if small wasn't
in fact nearly a quarter of house
republicans supported reaffirming equal
marriage rights the deadlock senate too
might get onside i want to bring this
bill to the floor the legislation is so
important
polling shows the vast majority of
americans are supportive of these
measures but the high court is now
harder to predict the court has been
captured by a very extreme right-wing
majority and
you know it's it it just invites
attention to the legitimacy of the court
can the united states still be seen as a
beacon of freedom given the fact that it
is now slowly starting to erode the
rights of people the american people and
those people who study the constitution
legal history don't know what this
conservative cohort is going to do next
because they're not following a logical
path and with little appetite at the
white house for changing the composition
of the court by adding more justices
vote vote vote vote the people whose
rights are at risk may hold ultimate
political power in november's midterm
elections
reggie shakini global news washington
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm tracy tong tonight's
your canada is the town of strathmore
alberta don't forget to send your photos
in thanks for watching vito garcia will
be broadcasting from edmonton tomorrow
for the pope's visit hope you can join
us then have a great night
[Music]
[Music]
you